hopefully for the new potato son yes
nicely lost ADA fell on taste very nice
but just ice Peter they hadn't gone into
the fryer Hyundai no no I assure you how
and put them in the fryer
yeah look mister let me just have a
quick words very very important this man
is paying your salary his business is
about to close
do you understand how critical the
situation is so pay the man [ __ ]
respect and tell the truth you have
deep-fried those potatoes no need for
another deep-fried they are wrinkled
dehydrated and they have been in the
deep fat fryer you're talking to a chef
and for as long as I've got a hole in my
butt big boy those [ __ ] potatoes have
been in the deep fat fryer don't [ __ ]
lie I know what they did you know the
ovens not even hot enough to roast a
potato
we can't even cook a [ __ ] burger in
there they've been in the fryer tell the
[ __ ] truth
there went in the other telling the
[ __ ] truth he's so adamant I've even
started to doubt my own judgment until I
tracked down Al Samar how many trays
appetizers you fired this morning
you fried all four and who told you the
fry them your chef there why did you
deep fry the potatoes you said this
earlier it's because you're beneath no
winning a hot game all right can we get
back to basics now okay I'm [ __ ] crap
sorry about [ __ ] hey liars
it's know rightfully that is me who's
asking you
forget about the [ __ ] camp I don't
sleep do you think that the only reason
I'm doing maybe these problems because
this is the last thing that I can do to
save the business
I want honesty for me that's all I want
don't be ever ever be scared of looking
like a prat but rather be an honest prat
don't rely of pride because then you'd
lose self-respect my mistake I can only
apologize for
if there's one thing worse than the chef
who can't cook it's the chef who tells
pork is my workload has just doubled and
there's only one way out of this
kilometres called e sack to get this
place back online we're gonna have to
close for two days there's no way on
earth we're ever gonna get the food back
up to scratch while you're sending what
you're sending out I need 48 hours we'll
work on tidying up the dining room
painting every member of staff working
for that goal to get it fresh and then
two days in the kitchen to get it on
track how'd you feel about it Israel
what can't afford not to take money but
we can't afford not to have a future
business yeah I think something that
wanted to stop is the [ __ ] mm-hmm I
need people to be honest with me Philip
are you ready for this if it is to make
the business better I'm a hundred
percent behind it's not just the kitchen
yeah yeah but I'm talking about the
dining room as well yeah there's a
serious you know improvement there to
take place so lack of pride a lack of
pride and the potatoes was a crime
[ __ ] example cut the [ __ ] you hit
the nail on the [ __ ] head and those
are pulling on the rope stay and work
those aren't interested in pulling on
the [ __ ] rope [ __ ] off
[Music]